what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation I have and haven't been this excited so
long because I'm here because Andrew's here we
have talked countlessly over the years about the
last of us as massive fans of the game I was like
I want to experience this as a gamer fan with my
closest friend who I talked about you know I'm
trying to get out here we're gonna watch The
Last of Us today people I am thrilled Andrew how
excited are you I am so pumped I've been actually
playing both games back to back I'm just so
knee-deep in Last of Us right now and I'm just so
pumped and so excited for this show what's really
important to me is I give you guys a heads up
though and I don't want anyone who hasn't played
the games to worry that Andrew and I are like ike
spoiling anything that might happen in future
episodes We're not gonna do any Telegraphing
in that regard so when it comes to talking about
the show or how it pertains to the game we're only
going to keep it about the episode itself we will
not do anything about what's supposed to happen
down the road or what might happen so if you
haven't played the game don't worry you can still
hang out with us here but if you have played the
game you might appreciate being here with us too
also John and Tara Erickson have not played the
game but they will be doing reactions for the
channel to provide you with a non-gamer
perspective LEAVE A LIKE that's what we
really ask you right now please go ahead leave
a like subscribe click that notification Bell
notify when I react for the next episode last
of us is up as always the full length Reaction
watch along as we sync up with your own copy
available for our super sexy rejects on our
patreon page we cover a bunch of stuff
exclusively with reaction highlights and
Watch Dogs included over there I just want to
get the ninja out of the way let's go to it
and that's your biggest worry yes any kind
of virus but most probably something similar
to influenza we end up with a global pandemic
and meaning all the whole world becomes sickle
at once damn that's Jonathan Hyde yeah you do
think microorganisms pose a threat or in the
most dire terms bacteria no oh Silicon Valley
not viruses so fungus because there are some
fungi who seek not to kill but to control
interesting the fungus needs food to live
so it begins to devour its host from within who
sat in the stage fungi cannot survive if it's
host's internal temperature is over 94 degrees
what if the world was to get slightly warmer ah
to spread the infection to every last human alive
by any means necessary so if that happens we lose
I love how they made it more relevant yeah
who will be back I think like global
warming and stuff that's interesting
yes
look at the fun guy such good music I love
that opening oh yeah they're
being worn decades in advance
that's
a great title opening I already have chills
oh wow we're starting way earlier I
mean like with Sarah like in the day
oh yeah yeah yeah I'm just gonna make
your birthday pancakes oh vitamin C
Joel loves his coffee how old are you again 36.
gonna have to wear diapers soon he says I don't
already stay alive yo oh he loves you he's
dependent on me not the same definitely the
same if I was having pancakes this sounds
exactly like him it does oh my goodness
Jakarta such a cool little detail right there
definitely a country maybe part of Asia your
part isn't a country being a part of Asia
is mutually exclusively being a country and
in fact it's capital of Indonesia damn
she's smart your t-shirt's inside out
hahaha
spooky looks just like the house yeah yeah it does
oh the watch yeah Connie was asking after you
that you hadn't been over in a while make him
happy get to know the neighbors we gotta run but
Sarah will be by later she'll stay as long as
you want tell you all about Atkins thank you how
exciting it was listen to that the conversation
I want you to write this diagram out exactly
as I have it okay we were watching this
in time clock
smart whole first episode from Sarah's perspective
which is in conjunction with the actual game
I also love too that we get to see the
lead up on the first day it's really cool
love it the apocalypse is just building okay
so we cannot finish I'm already finished
oh no
oh the tone just so changed there was
just a lot of police and stuff on the
road today people out there need to get right with
Jesus three Nails Plus One cross equals
four given Jesus would have stopped them
there's so much emphasis on the ticking
time clock yeah I love it be right there
oh no
that's creepy
hey Mrs Adler can I borrow this oh that's creepy
dogs can detect oh yeah
kill her Sarah wow
where's the cake
you got me in prison swear oh my love
it's great fix it for you
did you what I don't hear anything that was lame
yeah nice where'd you get the money for this
drugs I saw hardcore drugs and you
were never gonna do it for yourself so
thank you it's funny hard it feels like it's the
first time you're hearing it it doesn't feel like
they're just recreating it apart from the adlers
oh this is the one with the deleted scenes yeah uh
it's me uh I'm okay
it's Friday you don't get me out tonight I'm
in here all weekend idiot damn it tell me
what's this on the clocks he has a lot of time
wow
damn really sure briefly woke
her up to at least tell her
that's the details indoors law
enforcement and emergency services
are in the area and we'll be in
contact with further instructions
let the dog in
love how they just keep it from
a grounds view perspective on
the rising of the military coming in and stuff
come on let's get you home oh
no come on Mercy please Mercy
oh [__] it's like John
Carpenter directed this Mrs Adler
whoa
oh
oh my God
Ray reveal
oh the hair in the mouth
(They're Cordyceps Actually)
oh
won that [__]
oh dear
oh okay
what are we doing Joe
now at the sound design and the weapon so
just the adlers but we're going to be brave
and we're going to get out of this I really
like how they changed that up yeah that was
good Denise you get back inside the house you
lock your doors now come on come on get in
oh man Sarah's perspective oh that's
great yeah get your seatbelt on hold on
this is awesome
oh wow oh yeah
you're saying it's mostly people
in the city that's why they got
the highway blocked up I am loving this oh
look at that oh God damn it's Jimmy's Place
before I feel like they're choosing the
right [__] to be faithful with yeah
keep trapping oh I got a kid so do we keep driving
somebody else will come along
everybody had the same [__] idea
cut across and pick up on the
west side all right hang on
dude this is awesome
[__] [__] Army Tommy come on
call the razor crest Harbor blockade him around
fantastic capturing of the mood
whoa
holy crap foreign
move move
oh my God
damn oh wow that was a nice change
liquor noise well there can't be clickers
yeah I think it's uh foreshadowing
don't
gotta say this first 30 minutes is the best
video game adaptation so far in Mortal Kombat
oh man
head to the river I'll find a way get her out
of here Joe go dude these actors are killing it
foreign
man it's got the horror element down
damn stunt work here
shooting my daughter's hurt
her ankle stop right there
yes sir
we're not sick
sir we are not sick
I'm sorry please stop
okay you're okay you're okay move
your hand baby move your hand
s
I know I know I know I know baby I know I know
you're gonna be okay all right maybe
maybe listen to me I gotta get you up
all right come on you come on I know
baby no no I know I know I know [__]
come here no it's good hey let's
heartbreaking goddamn yeah [__]
she was great very good she
was great I was like really
invested in her yeah smartly the expansion on her
holy God wow
I should create some type of immersion experience
that is nuts oh Flawless what if I told
you that after we gave you some medicine
we're gonna find you your favorite food to
eat would you like that waffles you're safe
my name is Abby
Show's really smart it's taking the
time to do uh with his expansions to
explore the lifestyles more that's why
you gotta tap them in the shows can't
oh my god
wow dude Pedro Pascal's excellent
of capturing the contrast
rations I love it
hey crew 4 pm start
Gustavo Santa so good
infection
I love how there's so much set re
creation it's like real extras and
real costumes yeah real production
just really feels lived in come on
I just got a factory down there in the qz
supposedly only makes two things pills and
bullets bullets and pills the more you shoot
people the harder it is to sleep I guess
the back back I love the expansion on the
smuggling stay off the streets for the next
few nights the Firefly has been blowing [__]
up all week did you make a mistake in the dark
stay safe yeah you too it just looks like Joel
when you're lost in the
darkness look for the blood
Robert it's not like I planned on ripping
you off how about we just let it go
oh my guys [__] you up you're so discipline
them and cut off her finger or whatever the
[__] you want I don't care that
you're [__] guys the key answers
to me she won't hurt you and I'd like to go
home and drink till my face stops hurting
oh damn
I could see an explosion coming in there
well that guy got disciplined
God damn
you're shooting you're shooting at us
right
definitely different and I like
how you're capturing the uh
oh here we go emotionally tortured tesses
count slowly and clearly from one to ten
one two three four slowly seven eight
you let me out are you gonna pick I'm not
supposed to be here if Tommy responded we'd
know it's never taking more than a day to respond
I'm sure he's okay actually staying in contact
with Tommy show where the tower is Joel it's in
Wyoming Cody Tower qbar4 but I don't know exactly
he got you a cigarette never
stop trying to protect Tommy
glorious weapons now like in the game do after
a few hits they just stop working or is he like
this is an interesting touch more of an
alcoholic this time around just a little more
is more real
thank you and we're back in the game
like how they're leaning more into
the Romantic side of these two
I got jumped the guys who
jumped me away with Robert
I need the battery if I don't get to Tommy
soon he's gonna die out there okay okay we
get our money back and the battery eventual
interesting rewrite well where is he don't
know are we gonna find out quietly yeah
I promised Robert that he wouldn't hurt
him but I would very much like for you to
hurt him so let's go hunt that [__] down
and then we'll go find Tommy smart inclusion
it makes it feel more personal the mission yeah
to go after Robert not that it's just a job it's
actually there's a purpose and a reason behind it
oh Dandridge Marlene yeah it's so cool
they got the same actress we are in a
war against a military dictatorship to restore
democracy and freedom to the sound about right
does look like her yeah every Firefly in
Boston is going to gather in this building
and you're gonna leave the qz we're taking
that random girl locked in that room West
is this real I believe it
is goddamn right it's real
keep it quiet
look at her where she needs to go
just changed her whole optimism I
like the different ways they choose
to introduce these characters but then
it still segues into the game yeah will
give us more expansion now when you play the
game you're like oh maybe this character was
doing that even though there are obviously
different things that they're doing here
different which is a good show it's a
good show yeah yeah if you're feeling
lost tell me to look for the
line I'll break your Journal
he Robert by surprise
they got the foul mouth down she's
capturing the essence really well
but also the relationship between them capturing
it earlier is it gonna happen no so can I go
no not exactly where are you gonna
go back to Federal military school
they put me there when I was a baby it's
for Orphans they didn't put you there I did
oh Ellie Ellie I wish terrorist dumped me
with Federal because it's where you'd be
safest and you were safe there until you decided
to sneak out a terrorist was Riley a terrorist
oh I have a greater purpose than anything
ever imagined what I'm about to tell you
cannot be repeated to anyone because if you do
I assure you you will die you are the Cure Ellie
the sound I know right at
the sound design is so good
oh
so scary that you're in places like this with
infected I just love getting the expansion on
the characters like this hint at the
history and the games but you get to
really see it now like how Marlene and
Ellie became becoming her actual friend
Dan that looks great you think he
came down after he was infected
maybe down here is where he was infected I put
your mask on grass once they spot the spores they
will looks like they reframed the whole structure
everyone was cutting down on apartment sizes to
sell more condos this has been construction
corner with Joel Miller you smell that
oh okay that's Robert right is it I didn't
catch his face looked like Robert couldn't
the battery's no good still
tried to sell it yeah huh
oh he just stumbled upon this huh
oh
Joel So It Begins so this is who Robert
screwed us over with the che guevar of Boston
give me my knife what do you need
a car battery for dope not at her
we're gonna move Ellie out of the
Zone tonight so now I'm thinking
you're gonna do it I can do it you don't
have a [__] you're on your head could
you please oh yeah geez I don't know what
you're both capable of the better or worse
what are they capable of they'll give you what
you name it not just a battery the whole thing
[__]
really capturing the spirit of Ellie unfortunate
vehicle usually means repurpose Venture stuff
the second we hand that kid over y'all talk it
through but please remember that I'm bleeding
out nice nice but before we hand her over they
give us everything that we want if not we kill
her remember what I told you no go get your
backpack the new stipulations of this deal
made some wine changes
makes it more immediate Joel
I'm glad they got the same actors back
for that she's excellent I actually really
like the chemistry with uh her and Nelly
and also Joel and Marlene uh Joel and uh
Tess yeah you really get that history
of Survivor trauma bonding with them
the Journey Begins
foreign
truly reckon I'd like this show even if I hadn't
played the game but if you can score two people
who are so invested in the game that's that's
a good sign so who's Bill and Frank Bill and
Frank what are you doing killing time what am I
supposed to do I'm sure you'll figure that out
your watch is broken
so we're gonna be okay
yeah she has great lighting too so what's the deal
with you anyway you some kind of
bigwig's daughter or something
well the radio came on when
you're sleeping they kept
saying like wake me up before you
go go oh [__] gotcha code broken
such a smart ass I love it it's time to go
sneaking time
ugly's got a smuggle holy
[__] I'm actually outside
close your phone yeah yeah of course
let's go it really like nailed casting
from oh yeah everyone yeah they're all so
believable you bring the likeness to life
and if you haven't played the game
in life they're believable you know
I love the camera work in this too
oh I wonder if that's the same
cop that Joel spoke to earlier
oh there you go yeah you let us do
this run we'll split the cards with
you but will you yeah I'm so blessed
and on your head eyes forward hey
really man yep you're going to buy
the book oh [__] yeah I'm here
[__] we can fix this move
yeah I was just thinking that yep oh
damn dude damn pull it back Joel's
got a mean right hook pull it back
oh already I'm protecting the dog look look this
is three weeks old nobody that's more than a day
I love the look he gave back
did I make the right call
buddy
uh
interesting choice to break
perspective and come back here
holy crap that's such a great shot damn
it's gonna lightning flash yeah oh yeah
ah that was a damn quick uh one hour 19
minutes yeah that was excellent man that was
that was excellent I was absorbed yeah I couldn't
take my eyes off the screen I was so into that I
mean you made a really good point like even if you
were not a Die Hard fan or you had never played
the video games like you could still watch the
show not knowing anything and still find a way
to get invested in these characters and and
enjoy the World building that was happening
here but on the other hand if you are someone
who is obsessed with these video games like
they just like my biggest thing and this is not
meant to be a whole Disney like I can't stand
those live-action remakes that they make Beauty
and the Beast uh Aladdin and all that like I I
respect the visuals in those films but a lot of
times they they're just carbon copies and like
every time I'm watching a lot of those films I'm
like all right respect the filmmakers I love these
actors but this just feels like an exact carbon
copy remake of what I've seen originally whereas
this yeah they paid respect and homage in certain
areas and I'm sure the rest of the show is going
to do it if if this first episode uh you know is
has shown what it can do but just as a reminder
we won't talk about anything yeah yeah in the
future I'm not yeah I'm not I'm just I was just
saying for foreshadowing but I just love like the
stuff that they included the stuff that they left
out like it wasn't a case of like maybe if you're
a die-hard Harry Potter fan and you read the books
like ah they didn't include that or they've left
that out it's like no they actually did a really
good job of it's expanding a lot of things that
were talked about in quick conversation in the
first game but then really like we got to see
certain things like the whole first day of the
breakout like from Sarah's perspective the
whole build up the tension building and then
really getting invested and Sarah like obviously
if you play the game you're still saddened about
by what happens there but I felt myself like it
like really really extra sad in this just because
again we got the whole day to spend with her
like and she's such a uni is such an interesting
character she's really unique she's curious she's
smart uh she's got a great relationship with her
dad they've got that cute Bond ship that they
have with each other and and then obviously the
relationship the three of them have but I thought
this show this first episode was just just a great
way to start this off and I mean I I'm really a
harsh judge on this just because it's my second
favorite video game of all time for anyone who
doesn't know I've mentioned that before but I
thought this was a great introduction first
episode introduction for I mean for those who
haven't played the game like it starts off uh on
Sarah but it's it's like at the scene on the couch
basically that's the watch yeah yeah let's see
on the couch with the watch and then as opposed
to going to the neighbors you know Sarah wakes
up I'm forgetting the one part I'm forgetting
he doesn't go Bale Tommy out of jail is that no
I don't remember any of that in the game he was
just at he ran back into the house and then the
neighbors attacked and then Tommy and then Tommy
kept on calling on the cell phone yeah they attack
um Joel and Sarah's house yeah the neighbors and
then Tommy shows up versus how it sort of plays
out here but I like how they did here because
they a lot of times it seemed like a lot of the
choices they said were like how can we make this
feel more involved how can we make this feel more
personal rather than Sarah just being scared with
the neighbor attacking let's get to know the
neighbors so we can see some of the emotional
repercussions that come with it like I noticed a
lot with the the characters that he got with the
infected you would focus a lot on their eyes so
you would see a lot of the horror of the reactions
that you get from our our protagonists but then
you'd see a lot of the Menace in the eyes of the
infected and I thought that was a smart execution
because it does yeah the way they expanded time
here uh allows you to just become more more
invested and have things feel more personal
like I loved everything with Marlene uh not
Marlene sometimes I fluctuate the name loved
everything with uh Joel and Tess because yeah they
don't I mean it's obvious in the game that like
something's romantic yeah but but you kind of get
the sense like it's it's it's still super romantic
or is it like once in a while they kind of hook
up you know but here is no they're practically
like living together and they really care more for
each other like I like the touch of like looking
at her eyes and how he's just like ready to like
get revenge for them right away and so that was
that was a very neat touch and everything about
it they had like the Recreations of the the what
they were really capturing the most here that
is so important because yeah they it's not the
kind of thing if I I find this finding my words
right now I find this whole experience really
fascinating because it's as if they're aware this
game is massive so there's gonna be some [__]
that we're gonna have to be very faithful to and
so they're doing this they I think for a first
episode they really nailed it in a way that I feel
like would make video game fans happy and make
people who are not familiar with the game happy
and that's a really hard thing to do yeah and most
video game adaptations suck at that especially
ones like Last of Us which are such an involved
story where this the cut scenes and the cinematics
are such an intricate part of it and so it does
play on The Nostalgia Factor but it's not the way
they weave in the uh the expansions in the other
scenes feel necessary for the show experiences
if you just did a one-to-one adaptation it
wouldn't work as well and it would just feel like
a carbon copy like you talking about whereas here
it may and manages to make those scenes
where I'm like that is exactly the video game
still feel refreshing still feel unique and not
just I'm watching the game it actually has an
emotional effect versus I'm watching the same
beats happen again because of what they decide
to change because of what they decide to weave in
there because they are capturing the mood and the
experience so so well and uh I I I I I love this
I actually thought this was a really strong pilot
for for as a as a massive fan of the video game
but just as a fan of like damn good television
yeah like it's just really good it's really
good TV like another touch they added because
they they don't I love the inclusion of what they
did there at the end with with uh with the Joel
in the guard yeah because that's it that's great
that's in the game but they don't they don't do
the flashback right they yeah they don't they know
the Flash no it's just Ellie just stabs him and
then they shoot and that's it and then why are we
in why are we smuggling an infected girl there's
no none of the you know all the Joel having the
flashback and then all the grief just bottling
up and then he takes it out on that Garden none
of that was in in the game but yeah but it also
tells you for like a pilot like on a pie for
a first episode it's really smart because it's
cueing in the audience for thematically what these
characters are going to be going on in the journey
of what Joel will be going on like it's telling
the audience right there they're like I'm just to
be safe I won't say it but it's pretty obvious
you know the surrogate daughter thing you know
um I I thought that was a wonderfully wonderfully
done there are some stuff that like they obviously
changed you know with Robert there's like a
whole mission yeah yeah it's completely gone
um also too they made Joel uh an alcoholic in this
uh it feels into that yeah I mean like in the game
yeah I mean but now actually seeing it and you
know seeing popping pills it just it feels more
personal and you can relate to his situation a
lot more like actually seeing it rather than being
hinted at it so I actually like that inclusion I
also love the whole really expanding upon the I
mean obviously we saw in the beginning of the game
them being in the qz in Boston so we understand
that there is martial law but like seeing a
totalitarian government and like the ramifications
of what can happen obviously we did see hints
of or we saw stuff of that in the game but
actually seeing and then seeing all the extras
around like this would really suck to live in this
world and like that captures the coldness and the
brutality yeah for sure and and also too I really
thought they did a phenomenal phenomenal job of
just really Shifting the tone like on the first
day of outbreak like you know something's about
to happen but it's cheerful you're in a good mood
and then like you start like when things start
going sideways like the mood just again like you
feel the tension you feel like how dour it gets
and just I just thought this show just really
nailed that balance and the sound design in this
episode was Alaska and a lot of the characters too
you you nailed that they they got the likenesses
down and they just they know they just sounded
like them Luna has taught me too oh my goodness uh
Gabriel Gabriel Lunas I'm sorry Gabriel in my back
Gabriel Luna I mean it like goodness gracious
that's the weird part because it doesn't sound
like impersonations that's natural they sound
like they're really they're great performers
they're living that lived like you said lived in
they're they are the characters but they don't
sound like they're impersonating them definitely
which is kind of the worry that you run into but
like I don't know how they managed to [__] nail
that because even with like like because you know
I I uh it's funny because you said um Diego Luna
who's in Star Wars and Pedro Pascal who's a man of
Lauren and you know Amanda Lauren season two they
have um Katie Sackhoff who plays Boca Katana the
animated and and then in the live action and now
Merle Dandridge as Marlene yeah exactly and and
and there was something there that like I like
Katie sackhoff's performance in Mandalorian but
I was a little bit more aware of what they
were doing whereas here it it just I'm not
that I'm more like appreciative because I know
the character Marlene but I wasn't uh but it
just melded so naturally too and I was I was
kind of dazzled by how natural everything felt
absolutely and I love that introduction scene
we got with uh Bella Ramsay and Merle Dandridge
with uh Marlene and Ellie that that was yeah that
was such a I mean because again in the video game
as you all know or for those of you who haven't
played it uh we see the the first scene is where
Ellie tries to stab Joel with the knife uh you
know after Marlene brings them back so that was
really cool seeing that scene getting the setup
for their relationship just how she put her in uh
you know in the the federal military Camp uh
in Boston and that you know there there is a
history there so I just I really thought that was
such a great setup for their relationship because
we didn't really get to spend a lot of time with
Marlene and Nelly in the video game so just even
that that one little scene right there I really
appreciated that yeah because there are things
that are that are gonna happen that I imagine the
plot of this will has to go that we won't go into
right now but you you they do talk about like
Marlene's emotional investment in Ellie and we
didn't really get to see any of that in the game
and here they gave us that and I was like oh yeah
that's clever it just sounds like a little moment
like don't point the gun at her point and I mean
just little things like that what you're saying
the trust with the yeah oh yeah I haven't had a
clue but also the trust in the like with that when
he when she does give give her the backpack and
the knife and then she just sits right close to
him like oh that's great you're building the bond
yeah yeah without spoiling [__] like good
stuff's to come that's good stuff's coming and
and I I think the changes they make are smart
like sure what I have liked the mission with
Robert yeah but you know when I think back on
the game I'm not like Ben that is such such an
important plot point I'm like now you can it that
that's showing that that's showing you kind of
the lifestyle of what they get and it leads into
the Marlene stuff but they gave us other things
to show you like how they make money and rations
oh and I like the inclusion of how he's looking
for Tommy yeah because that's not in the game
not at all and so to and but I you know I like
obviously Tommy would come back around but the
to start off there again that just makes it more
personal that that that creates a thread of of a
bunch of more things to make you look forward to
stuff so I think if you haven't played the game
like it's not a change to me that upsets me I'm
like no that's smart for television yeah that
makes it more and because now you're like okay
when's Tommy gonna what's Tommy been up to like
we have an idea but as an audience member you're
like what's going on there why we can't we get a
hold of Tommy yeah no if you make changes for the
better that serve the plot in an interesting and
satisfactory way then I'm I'm all for it I still
have the the mission from the video game so it's
not the end of the world again if it betters the
plot and is done in a very satisfying way I'm
all for it and that that uh getting rid of the
whole Robert mission that didn't bother me
in any way shape or form no I mean you got
some cool violence in the Rock they share in the
game it shows you how violent Joel's but see Dad
get to see that with the guards exactly so that
was fine that's why it's a great choice because
it it's the introduction of the impact of showing
how violent Joel can get whereas in the game that
is with like with the Robert stuff and they're
like shooting some people it's like it seems
like they're choosing which moments to show the
violence or the violence has an emotional impact
for the characters versus sometimes in the games
you're just like killing people and not only that
I like that Ellie got to see right away how how
crazy Joel can be too so I thought that was an
interesting choice because again I don't think in
the video games you saw that side of Joel that or
that quickly I mean because I mean they're only
5-10 minutes into their mission it seems like at
that point when she sees him just you know going
Raging Bull on the guys so I mean I thought that
was again just a bold and interesting choice
that serves the plot and done in a satisfactory
way and one last thing uh I really love the
last thing I feel like I talked for hours
I really did like the whole symbolism and the
whole theme of just out of time with showing all
the clocks and the watches and all that because
I mean it was basically just a countdown to the
world just completely changing and flipping on
its heads yeah I thought that was again just
really wise choices the cinematography and the
steps episode the sound design it was really well
for I mean it really didn't feel like an hour
and 19 minutes I was like I couldn't believe
the episode was done I had to remind myself
that there was a camera I was like oh yeah
yeah I need to sometimes say something because
I was like I was back to just playing the game
yeah it was like quiet and paying attention yeah
yeah no it was really really strong first episode
and the music too okay Gustavo sent out him I
think it's great because they I've definitely
played some I've definitely seen some video game
adaptations where I'm like I'm familiar with the
game and I watch it and I'm like oh this just
seems manipulative or pandering and this was
the first time I was watching this like really
experiencing as an avid game lover of they are
they are really bringing this to life in
a way that feels more than satisfactory
um just for one second like you're so shocking
Gabriel Luna's voice I don't remember oh the
Tommy Boy that was just unbelievable what the
[__] what does he sound like exactly like
it's like did they have Jeffrey Pierce like
doing the debit nods Gabriel Luna like that's
that was really really impressive like the first
time you said I was like it did sound alone then
I heard a couple more lines like holy crap it
sounds just like just like it was not like an
impersonation it naturally sounds like Tommy then
they do stuff to specifically make game lovers get
excited about [__] you know like when they are
doing the Sarah scene in the car where they go
into her perspective yeah I'm like oh man they
are recreating this specifically more than just
like that's how it is in the game so we have to
do it yeah they do [__] where you're like the
game lovers are gonna love this and I'm like yeah
this is working for me and they also they did a
fake out too because nor in the game the car hits
uh they crash a car crashes into them and then in
this the car almost crashes into him fake out and
then you got the airplane that lands a great touch
good touch no I thought that was really again
really so so uh subvertive and like it but done
in an interesting and satisfactory way I feel
like that's going to be a common theme of words
I use a lot on this show if this first episode
is anything to run by but fantastic first episode
again even if I wasn't a massive fan of this I'd
really love this first episode but being a massive
fan like this is again just first episode one of
the best video game adaptations I've ever seen
just from a first episode I know that's a quick
remark to make after the first episode but this
was just really really well done like and again
I try making this a movie at first I'm like what
are you nuts it's got it it'd have to be like
I've been saying it for years that like video
game especially ones that are so story based
yeah they have to be TV shows yeah you need to
spend more time with these characters if this show
remains consistent for the remainder of the season
it's we have a revolution videos yeah no it is
a it is a testament to like no this is why video
games should be television shows yeah and and just
this pilot alone which has only scratched like
barely scratched surface yeah we're barely like
the in the game you're like oh oh the missions
finally started yeah and that's what where it
leads you on um I think it's so smart I can't
wait to see how some of the action scenes are done
yeah but it but it doesn't feel like they're gonna
do action scenes seems they're gonna do violence
you know and I think we'd be remiss tonight it
really quickly mentioned I thought they nailed the
look of the clickers like just put the hair out of
the mouth and that scary tension Vibe like yeah
we haven't got our full-on we got first thing I
didn't say clicker I said Runner you say clicker
I did oh okay sorry play it back it's the Colorado
uh Snapchat in my brain but now I I the runner
the runner I'm sorry I think you were right it's
a quick the runner the runner that we saw at
the beginning uh the neighbor at the Adler's
house I believe they said I thought they and some
of the other Runners that we saw like God I love
this stuff the 10 the tension you feel I mean I
made a comment saying this it really feels like
a John Carpenter film like I was really doing
a good job of building tension in a way like
in the game you do feel that but it's it's hard
to describe the differences you feel when you're
watching it like actually like cinematically on
a TV show but I thought they did it just a great
again that's that's the Nuance of balances that
I'm I already loved in this first episode there's
so many different things that they were able to to
accomplish and really balance out so really really
good first episode well with the game you have to
you you are the player you're in control you're
in control so you're in it and so with a show you
do have to expand because you have to do more work
to make the audience feel in it yeah you just have
to because there's already a natural subconscious
thing that happens as as the player versus when
you're not actually the player you have to do more
work and be and be and that more work I think is
they definitely paying off to make you feel more
to make you feel more involved I I do think with
Bella Ramsey she's really capturing the essence
and there are times in her performance and I'm
like sometimes it still feels like I'm aware
you're acting but for the most part I wouldn't say
that for the most part I'm like I'm loving what
you're doing Petra Pascal is killing it oh yeah
Pedro Pascal is just [__] yeah he's an alien
and just really quickly on Bella Ramsay I I from I
can totally understand sympathize with what you're
saying I think from a perspective of just the foul
mouth smart ass like she's got that portion down
in my opinion so far so far yeah I think I think
actually yeah it's first episode yeah no first
episode but no I'm I'm curious to see as we spend
more time and we expand upon the show like I'm
I am more curious to see just you know how more
into character she gets as Ellie because so far I
like her I like her I I like her I haven't fallen
in love with her yet but not much time has been
spent right you know and and uh and we have to
see the development of the relationship with her
and Joel because that's the heart of everything
right of course um and then like okay if that's
down then I'm like boom yeah we're holding Hook
Line and sink or if you get that relationship down
I was really impressed yeah that was great they
[__] did it man I did it the the build up to
that that was a great first episode they and
I love where they ended it too like that was
perfect ending as well like great yeah because
it's setting up themes character Mission at hand
and now um going to the other side of the
wall you know like oh we're about to really
see some [__] like you have not seen anything
at all no no and even story-wide like more than
visuals like story-wise yeah yeah it's just oh
there's so much more to tap into that you know
they're going to if if this first episode's a
testament at all to where they might go yeah
um I'm excited I uh I I really loved it and uh
now now this is why I wanted to watch this with
a fellow gamer yeah because that was that was
amazing yeah that was great I was so impressed
with that I was so impressed with that uh yeah
well what'd you guys think of the first episode
did you love it what qualms did you have um be
curious to know be curious to know subscribe
leave a like and uh hey we'll we'll catch you all
soon follow Andrew thank you guys for being here